للمره الاولى في التاريخ توصل لجنه في
الكونجرس بتوجيهتها من جنائيه لرئيس
الامريكي السابق
باجماع كل اعضاء لجنه التحقيق في احداث
اقتحام الكونجرس في السادس من يناير رفعت
توصيات بتوجيه اربع تهاما للرئيس السابق
وهي عرقله عمل الكونجرس والتامر الاحتلال
على الحكومه الامريكيه وتقديم تصريحات
كاذبه والتحريض على التمرد
من سايدس
الدستوريه في السادس من يناير عام 2021
عباره عن مئات من المخالفات الاجراميه وقد
شرعت وزاره العدل في تتبع معظم تلك
الجرائم قضائيا نقترح على اللجنه ان تمضي
قدما في الاحالات على جهاز العداله وفق
خطوره المخالفه والضلال الناجمه عنها
واهميه دور الفاعل ضمن المخطط غير
القانوني الرامي الى قلب نتيجه الانتخابات
والتي تجبرنا على ان نقول ما في انفسنا
الخطوه بانها رمزيه على اعتبار ان
الكونجرس لا يملك صلاحيه توجيه التهم
بنفسه ولان هذه التوصيات غير ملزمه لوزاره
العدل لكنها في الوقت نفسه تزيد من الضغوط
على وزير العدل وعلى المحقق الخاص جاكسون
الذي يتولى التحقيقات المتعلقه بترامب
وللاستفاده ايضا من الادله التي جمعتها
اللجنه
لاننا نستند الى ماده تاريخ
قضائيه لذا لا اصفها بالرمزيه وارى انها
مهمه ليس فقط
لانها ايضا مدعومه بوفره التي تظهر سلوكا
بانها غير مزوره كما قدمت ادله على مزاعيه
لقلب النتيجه والضغط على وزاره العدل
ومسؤولين انتخابينا وعلى نائبه مايكل ومن
ثم اقدامه على تشجيع انصاره على اقتحام
الكونجرس وعدم تحركه او اتخاذه اي اجراء
او
قاط ساعات الاقتحام وقد علقت نائبه رئيس
لجنه التحقيق في احداث السادس منير بان
افعال ترامب تجعله غير مناسب لشغل منصب
الحكوميا في المستقبل
بهذه الخطوه التاريخيه وبتصديها في اخر
جلسه لها على تقريرها نهائي الذي سيشرو
هذا الاسبوع تختتموا لجنه التحقيق في
احداث اقتحام الكونغ روسي في السادس من
يناير ثمانيه عشر شهرا من التحقيقات شملت
تسعه جلسات علنيه وشهادات اكثر من 1,000
شخص والحصول على اكثر من مليونين وثيقه
بسنه كويك الجزيره واشنطن